leading a union requires that you know
you are able to articulate the issues
that your members are feeling that you
have some ability to inspire them to act
when action is needed and that you are
loyal to the members and that you truly
do represent their wishes and their
ideas and not some weird version of your
own and I think that that's what gives
you sort of longevity and endurance I
mean anybody can sort of run for union
office and become a technically a union
leader but to sort of have any longevity
instead you've got to really feel it
you've got to have a passion about it
and you have to believe that your
members know what's right
you